being at a net worth of 230 billion
roughly being perceived as the richest
person on earth well i think putin is
significantly richer than me you really
do yeah yes
there's something you have to understand
about the force billionaire list it's
not true it is a complete lie
here's why
most people on the force billionaire
list like elon musk and jeff bezos are
there because they have no choice most
of their money is in public companies so
it's insanely easy to get a good
estimate of how much they're worth plus
most people on the list made their money
in the last few decades while there have
been centuries of banking families
industrialist royal families that have
all been accumulating wealth way longer
than the forced list has and you're
telling me that no one has more
generational wealth than elon musk
individuals and families who are truly
wealthy i'm talking old money wealth
they don't want the world to know how
rich they are if you have a lot of
wealth that can be taken that can be
taxed that can be published or even
seized why would you want to flaunt your
wealth if you made your money in a shady
or controversial way like banking fraud
or being a dictator why would you want
the world to know how much you're worth
and that's where our guy vladimir putin
comes in
he's ruled the biggest country on earth
with an iron fist for 18 years
multi-billionaire russian oligarchs have
the answer to his every beckon call or
they risk getting their wealth taken
from them being thrown in prison exiled
assassinated or all of the above
putin runs one of the most corrupt
governments in the world and yet when
you look at his wealth on paper it tells
the story of a humble civil servant
living off an even humbler salary
according to the kremlin putin only
makes around 140 000 a year by
presidential standards that's not much
his public assets include two small
apartments in russia a trailer worth 800
and three kind of cheap cars
on paper putin is such a selfless leader
he can't be corrupt he only draws a
lotta
and when asked about how much money he
really has his go-to reply is always i
am the wealthiest man not just in europe
but in the whole world i collect
emotions i am wealthy in that the people
of russia have twice entrusted me with
the leadership of a great nation such as
russia i believe that that is my
greatest wealth
so noble right
over the years reports have come out
that vladimir putin isn't just rich he
is filthy rich
in fact most estimates put his net worth
at around 285 billion dollars a nice and
easy 20 billion dollars above elon musk
and what has that 285 billion dollars
bought him off the record at least 700
cars 58 planes and helicopters a 1.4
billion dollar mansion with its own ice
hockey rink casino nightclub and
amphitheater wore just one toilet brush
and the mansion cost 850 dollars and an
insanely expensive watch collection
which is one watch costing half a
million dollars
in literally two decades vladimir putin
went from a low level civil servant to
being the richest man in the world and
no one knows for sure how
turns out there's two theories that help
putin secretly became the world's
richest man
most billionaires on the forbes list got
there because of their business but
today finding that right business idea
that right opportunity is tricky it
feels like everything has already been
done and there's no room for innovation
but what if you had access to thousands
of great vetted business ideas at your
fingertips well that is where trends
comes in trends is an insanely valuable
online knowledge hub for aspiring
entrepreneurs basically trend
specializes in sending you the next big
startup ideas months before everyone
else catches on here's how it works
trends team of expert business analysts
vet thousands of business ideas and
analyzes market trends to send the best
ones straight into your inbox every week
and in doing so they save you months of
research thousands of dollars and all
the regret of not starting sooner but
that is not all trends also gives you
access to an ambitious community of over
15 000 people all rooting for your
success and who knows one of those 15
000 people could be your next co-founder
or investor take norak for example he
was a trans member when trent's
uncovered signals that the indoor plan
business was set to boom trends sent the
signal out to their members and the rect
took that report and launched a d2c plan
startup nerec announced the project in
the trends community received some
valuable advice from other members and
started building 40 days later he raised
1.5 million dollars in funding then
there's chris who built his third party
logistics company send eats based on
their article about the anything as a
service trend chris has grown from one
customer at around 200 orders a month to
27 customers with hundreds of thousands
of revenue finding the next big idea
just got easy all you have to do is head
to trends.com jaytran with the link
below and sign up and if you follow that
link you'll also get a 7 day trial of
trends for just one dollar that's
trends.co jaketrain with the link below
thanks to trent for sponsoring this
video
it's the summer of the year 2000 in
moscow 21 of russia's richest men the
oligarchs arrive at the kremlin for a
special meeting under president boris
yeltsin they've had years of free reign
to do whatever they wanted but putin is
about to put them in their place as the
newly elected president of russia
vladimir putin knows all too well how
corrupt the oligarchs are but instead of
arresting or finding them he offers them
a deal pledged their absolute loyalty to
him as the new president and they get to
keep their billions their houses yachts
and private jets to the oligarchs it
seems like a good enough deal sure putin
may not be as easy to control as boris
yeltsin but as either obey him or face
his wrath so the 21 men agree and for
three years everything runs as smoothly
as expected until a man named mikhail
korkowski is arrested for years maquel
had been making millions from russian
corruption and now suddenly he wants to
call out putin for not doing anything to
stop it in february 2003 maquel picks a
fight with putin on live tv a few months
later he's conveniently arrested and
charged with fraud and tax evasion
mckell was sentenced to nine years in
jail but instead he gets sent to a
siberian labor camp to all the oligarchs
out there the message was clear don't
bite the hand that feeds you but for
putin a warning isn't enough so he
gathers the oligos again this time the
terms of the deal aren't as simple this
time he wants a 50 50 splits 50 of all
the oligarchs money in exchange for
their freedom as president putin gets to
choose who lives or dies who gets to
keep their businesses and who gets sent
to prison it's only fair he gets
something in return for his protection
rights basically putin told them if you
agree i'll take 50 of your money but
you'll get to keep your businesses your
houses and your freedom if you don't
accept this offer i'll take a hundred
percent of everything you have and
you'll end up like our guy mckell in
siberia it's easy to see why most of the
oligarchs agreed according to bill
bowder a top american investor in russia
this deal scored putin an easy 200
billion dollars back in the early 2000s
half of everything the oligarchs owned
after nearly two decades in power it's
easy to imagine how that 200 billion
became 285 billion as long as putin kept
hustling more wealthy russians into his
deal every time an oligarch got
assassinated or exiled for criticizing
the governments putin would swoop in and
collect his 100
as long as the loyal oligarchs keep
making money putin will keep getting
richer or at least that's one theory
[Music]
[Music]
as the leader of russia putin has every
russian politician at his beck and call
he also has the ultimate say over who
becomes minister of what and putin has
used that power to make himself one of
the most protected presidents in the
world for decades he's brought his old
kgb and fsb friends into politics he's
appointed these people of force or
slovakia into all the top government
positions the military strong men aren't
the only ones benefiting from important
positions in the governments this is
arcardi rottenberg putin's childhood
friend and judo partner in the early
2010s arcardi received over seven
billion dollars in state contracts
leading up to the 2014 sochi olympics
he's also the co-owner of russia's
biggest gas and electricity supply line
construction company today he's worth
around 2 billion
who appointed him to this position
vladimir putin of course
meet kiril shamolov putin's
ex-son-in-law shem allah became a
billionaire at just 34 years old after
getting a major low from gazprom bank so
he could buy a 17 stake in a company
owned by one of putin's closest friends
along with the slovakia putin recruits
everyone he trusts from family members
to friends to bodyguards to get involved
with state-owned companies he makes sure
that they become leaders of all the
biggest companies and get the best
contracts and in return he gets a
generous cut of their success the money
might not be in putin's own accounts the
house's cars yachts jets might not be
under his name but control is the name
of the game here not ownership on paper
as long as you have de facto control of
an assets like a house or a super yacht
meaning that you get to do whatever you
want with it as if you owned it you get
all the benefits of ownership without
alerting the public to how much money
you have
[Music]
this is svetlana kraven nogic a former
cleaning lady turned multi-millionaire
she's also the owner of a 4 million
luxury apartment in the heart of monaco
one of the most expensive in the world
and though she didn't work herself out
of poverty she's vladimir putin's
alleged mistress while one of them
for years people have been trying to
figure out how vladimir putin can be the
richest man in the world but have no
paper trails leading to him and his
money one of those answers could be
svetlana or whatever his other
mysterious names are after the panama
papers and the pandora papers were
released we all got a pretty vague look
at the offshore account owned by putin's
friends family and mistresses and boy
were they full i'm not in a position to
give you figures but what i can say is
that he supposedly draws a state salary
of something like 110 000 a year that is
not an accurate statement of the man's
wealth
and he has long time
training and practices in terms of how
to
mask his actual wealth is vladimir putin
corrupt in our view yes
i know from my business partner that
putin asked for a share in the business
initially they were asking for 15
he called him greedy
he managed to talk them down to four
percent
obviously this wasn't registered in any
official papers another theory as to how
putin has all his money is that he uses
the names of the people closest to him
to open offshore accounts all around the
world for him to store his money in
these are documents from one of the
offshore companies that diverted
millions of dollars to the palace and
according to kelesnikov the owner of
this company was putin himself
obviously none of these people will ever
steal a sense because everyone knows
what happens if you cross putin putin
might not have anything linking him to
billions but everyone around him does
from his daughter's godfather to his
former mistress has gennady timchenko
been holding wealth of vladimir putin do
you think
it's uh i don't know if i would put it
exactly that way in terms of holding his
wealth i can say that he has been
tremendously enriched personally by
vladimir putin as have another handful
of people in putin's inner circle
and of course there are allegations
suspicions that he holds tremendous
amounts of putin's wealth
himself that
you see sometimes he could
just pointing up
in
in talks and saying that
is everything is controlled
by michael and
michael and she's a nickname for the
putin and when he's not hiding his money
with his friends he's likely using some
of it to buy up gold russia has some of
the biggest gold reserves in the world
worth around 120 billion dollars
obviously not all of it belongs to putin
but i wouldn't be surprised if a good
chunk does
no one is ever allowed to talk about
putin's personal life on tv or social
media in russia so it's not like anyone
is going to risk their life to share
something as sensitive as where he hides
his money my guess is that he uses a mix
of all the strategies we talked about
today all we really know is that if
putin is the richest man in the world
the only chance we have of really
finding out is maybe if he dies
do you think that putin is the world's
richest man let me know in the comments
below and if you're new here my name is
jake and this is one of the biggest
channels for documentaries on money
power and crime so if you like this one
click that subscribe button below for
multiple documentaries every single week
just like this one for free and if you
want longer and more controversial ones
that i can't post publicly you can click
that join button below and if you join
in don't think it's worth it i will
refund you the money just email me
anyways that's gonna wrap it up thank
you so much for watching stay dangerous
out there and i will see you guys in the
next one
you